this week's videos are sponsored by
expressvpn more on them after the
reaction
people
Purge you can't be drinking while I go
to purge I really can't take two Purge
this is the reject Nation it is time for
Purge three we are Betty and Veronica we
are who are the other people I compar to
and Louise yeah we are T Roy Batman and
Robin which one's
Batman we will be your Purge mommies for
the day your Purge sisters but we can't
take the place of purge Daddy no nobody
can we know who Purge daddy is so hot
Frank is there going this there better
be that's not really how this franchise
works yeah probably not a little sad
when I think about it unless he's
running for president I don't know what
this is but it is election year sounds
like it will be really peaceful as all
election years are with no uh
disapproving looks or different opinions
at
all oh
that's not true I hope it's as much fun
as the first two though if you guys do
too like this video comment subscribe
yes and ring the
bell ring the
bell that was a purge at the end that
had some Gusto yeah purging it you
really wanted them to ring the bell and
I want you guys to be as sexy as
possible and what that means is that you
have to go over to patreon become a
super sexy reject over there where you
can link up with your own copy Greg and
John cover several shows exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included that's for the sexy
people only super sexy what are we
purging this time what are we getting
rid of what oh right what are we
actually getting rid of
um okay good yes and fear we're purging
fear today fear have no fear it's
election year yeah baby that was good
she brought it
back doing it Purge Purge we're doing it
okay do I push you harder every time
she's getting aggressive listen she's a
fortress I am not yes I am a fortress
I'm a fortress that's a whole foot
shorter than
you hi bir
mommy bum it's funny cuz we have no
mommies we don't we're both momless so
we'll be your Birch mom me and Roxy will
be will be fillings for you guys who
also don't have moms in the market for a
purge mommy we've got we right
here okay Tunes to start setting a Vibe
I'm loving it I'm excited it makes me
feel like we're in a different
decade are they having what are we
hearing ooh T-Rex that's one of my
nicknames really
yeah
[Music]
any going oh snap okay we in it
had my Purge playlist I put a lot of
thought into it okay
Joker and then I thought George Clinton
the king of interplanetary
funmor is psychedelic Rock would leave
you feeling funky George Clinton is
funky now they've played a lot of per
games tonight are those googly eyes on
his cheeks yeah it's called mommy's
Choice momy which one of you will
survive this year's Purge oh it's like
borrowing from Sophie's
Choice okay so he's the most Sinister
villain that we've seen like straight up
so far right yeah and like immediately
18 years later what two days before the
annual what year are we in this is just
one of a dozen protests around our
Capital after reports emerged claiming
that the new founding fathers had been
using the purge to help their own
economic agenda this we by incendiary
Purge detractor Dante Bishop for the
past 20 years God there he is less
welfare less health care less housing a
Monumental effect on the upcoming
presidential election Ed Owens has been
losing ground to wildcard independent
candidate Senator Charlie ran oh yet
from Lost Ron was forced to watch the
brutal execution of her entire family on
Purge Night with one goal in mind to put
an end to the annual holiday the
greatest threat to the nffa regime so
there's literally a purge Mommy now yeah
she's it would she be our mommy please
if we ask
nicely we have our people out there
countering all this anti- nffa
feels really not like BS all these
idealistic pigs they want the
impossible everyone to
have it's not impossible not even close
some cannot have not enough to go around
it's so not true there are billions and
billions to go around trillion so much
we are going to use this year's Purge to
do some spring cleaning gentlemen there
are people who really talk like that my
God and it's so scary I'm like dude if
you just sold your yacht you could take
care of like 30,000 people one of their
five Yachts yeah just sell one of the
Yachts just one where our great nffa
leaders gather together and Slaughter
Innocents is murder our new religion
murder is our new religion that's Snappy
the midnight Purge Mass where NFA
leaders gather to celebrate he looks
like Mitt Romney
sorry
yeah oh God who this who the oh good
looking good looking there you don't
recognize Frank yeah it is time to call
upon the better angels of our nature get
it Purge Mama secure the audience on I'd
like to talk to you guys what is he from
Chief that's bugging me she's no good to
anyone dead which one this
the the the big the handsome guy yeah
like from the from other from the other
thing that I just watched though Rock
The
Purge he's from The Purge you're making
a joke I know I'm like he's was just in
a recent movie The Purge babe the one we
just saw no The Purge too no he's in
that too that's perch daddy bab that's
Frank
gillo
no what wait what am I going crazy are
you having a
stroke oh my God she can do it all that
useless can't butter a damn Bagel
correctly I go butter your bagel boss he
is um what is his name what is his name
he's very famous you just be careful kid
with all that hope because it can be a
bad thing hope can lead to a lot of let
down yeah hope is not good to have I
carry none of it my heart was Obama's
full
slogan hope can change the
world March 20th here we go Pisces
season get those blue flowers get them
rocking the rules protecting level 10
government officials have been revoked
NFA is revoking The Purge rule that
protects government officials is ranking
10 on Purge
night if the voters get wind that I'm
hiding in a fortress like some rich
I lose votes and the nffa wins I
stay home like 99% of the population
that's right Purge Mommy get it it's
like when people in office don't put
their kids in public school and it's
just like do you not even believe in
your own school system like that's true
if you don't believe in your own
government you can't
rule okay that legitimately scared me I
also know her from something she's a
fortress y'all she does not get scared
come on
inside The Purge is Halloween for adults
h no oh God where's the candy this guy's
nuts we here to experience the purge to
kill release all the anger and hate
murder tourism it's the new booming
business in our country this year
shouldn't you just like close the
borders during The Purge be like you
can't come in here next time you need
something just give us a call I'll have
Marcos run it open and save you the trip
okay I come by to flirt with you
Joe me you better get out these girls
going to steal oh hey girl hey okay
okay what are these girls
doing oh they're being rude yeah I don't
like it all right girls give it up I
won't have to call the police give up to
candy or I'll have to take it away from
you you touch me and I scream damn dude
give it
back who are you I feel like she's
the real purge Mama now Lany Rucker OG
Queen badass they called you B W you're
my mother hero now give back whatever
you stole okay I'm changing Purge Mama
to her sorry mister I was just playing
you look all whitish now wish I met you
back in the day a lot of ecus yeah yeah
like we're like all up in there we are I
kind of like it it keeps me like super
invested I'm revamping the entire thing
we got new barricades on all the doors
all the windows back and front looks
safe Chief if you tell me it's safe once
one more time I'm going to throw you
down the steps please don't do
that that was the funniest line of the
whole
series and on
everything
B why are you raising my rates now do
you today do you know what today is yeah
I'm talking to you let me speak to your
super your
super you should not be allowed to raise
people's damn insurance company
they just raised a premium on my Purge
coveries just in general but thousands
holy I have no Purge coverage for this
store holy oh my god dude this is
terrible take over the government I just
have to protect this place myself
no how are you feeling about these
Graphics this time they're not the same
they're kind of the same right from the
last one I don't know do we get again I
thought that the guy that I was seeing
earlier today is not the same guy from
the past M I think when you see him out
in these streets you're going to know
I'm to remember
I started to think I I was like he's not
The Walking Dead guy that I was thinking
about andw Lincoln no you ready yeah
yeah okay let's go oh I love her they
get some really good actors in This
franchise I will say I like this
wouldn't work if they were crap no this
is your emergency broadcast system
announcing the commencement of the
annual Purge fire and Emergency Medical
Services will be unavailable until
tomorrow morning I wonder who they're
going to help no one has been granted
special immunity from The Purge no
citizen or group will be exempt oh so I
said about the
government right y all got to come in
nobody's exempt bro wow get ready and we
already know the security gates they're
[Music]
breakable I like have Goosebumps I don't
know some music and the establishing
shots but I feel like ready Eric thank
you for being here tonight my pleasure
Leo have a drink with me you don't have
a choice what purge mommy says Purge
Mommy gets I want them to hook up
immediately they're gonna they're gonna
I've wanted them to hook up with
everybody I know right now we'll we
might get to see bir daddy sherz like I
asked want me to apply for this position
I lost my son some years ago I almost
did something on Purge night that would
have destroyed a lot of lives I Want
This Night gone you remembering all that
now it's all back despite all that you
you have a big problem with how I do
things you take risks Senator my job is
to eliminate risks and keep you alive
she is putting her people at risk the
only way that I can win is to risk
everything and that includes my life I
respect it she's a woman and she means
business and she's hot but that's not
the point I hope Purge mommy takes off
her shirt too you said it but we were
all thinking
[Laughter]
it they probably won't bother us
okay no thank you that one was a little
nerve-wracking for me okay good maybe
she's not a full
Fortress oh that was wild why are they
like risking their lives I mean they're
doing a good thing but I'm also like
ah
whoa we brought a guillotine whoa that
is a wild shot is that kid wearing an
alien that was
intense oh no
no oh that's rough like are there just
this many people that are psychotic in
this country I guess
so I thought I was going to say
[Laughter]
p
pu oh please stop please help him and
how are going down going to decipher if
it's like good or bad could be a
setup but you got this guy's like one of
the best snipers ever yeah for sure I
feel
it
oh it's Purge Night you don't sneak up
on black
people good night blue cheese good night
blue cheese what is that I don't even
know but that's hilarious what the is
good night blue cheese
chees good night blue jeez it's got to
be improv right yeah I guess so I'll
stay I want you to go home and be safe I
don't want you out here on Purge night
son oh no is he here to set him up no I
hope
no that would break my heart is this car
glowing
okay all right I should do that wild
looking for Christmas like how cool does
that look can't be safe but for
Christmas it's okay in the
USA I don't think this is what Miley
meant oh my
goodness kiss me no thanks imagine
deciding to do this it is like adult
Halloween with the costumes right now
right and a bedazzled gun what is
happening mostly just so they can open
the doors with all those lights on it
they did some good
engineering okay let's see your face oh
the girl the sh it you Snickers
stealer what's he going to do shoot her
ooh there's your warning shot and I want
my candy bar and I'm going to take it
you don't got the balls to stop
me nice shot that was from the kid now
go I already took care of my mom and dad
tonight what oh dang uh y'all should
kill her just put her out of her misery
what's up with that every day in was
like The Purge I know how to shot bus
yeah you do said well what's up with
that I thought you were just blue cheese
but man you can snipe yeah because if
you missed she was
dead good time for
brusi always a good time I don't know
it's that time it's that time he knew
Purge Fortress good one so good great
timing when the old guy came in just
that was
scary feel like you're agist bro
gosh all the stories in these movies
combine I'm interested how Purge Daddy
and Juliet from lost story is going to
combine with yeah the guy with the store
store yeah yeah what are you still doing
up here you're on first floor Duty how
was the chck some lightning go there's a
mole Chief find a bedroom I got it from
here all right Leo feel like it's that
guy the old guy the bald the balding guy
you just if it is him you're
right for sure that was her mom who
saved her right and that was her as a
kid yeah yeah you're right got to be yes
yeah okay well her Purge mommy saved her
yeah so now you it's your turn to be a
mommy with Purge daddy don't you take a
break
go watch some TV huh it's going to be a
long night please sir I'm skeptical of
the guy who just cleared um that guy I'm
skeptical of
them okay is Leo watching or no oh my
goodness okay SWAT coming for you honey
white power wow oh God okay so tell me
how you feel yeah what do you guys stand
for what do you guys think about mostly
imagine getting that embroidered on
something like you send it out for
embroider yeah who's everyone's like
H wait is he opening the oh you might
have been right about him knew it okay
you knew it what's going on with Pur D
that text message like all set or
whatever yeah I think he has it on Loop
he must have it on Loop or something
yeah fudge must have mess with it
nothing going on Purge daddy you ready
for this you better get ready you want
smoke no you better you don't want that
Purge daddy smoke how you doing your
skills would have come to light him but
Bobby's not getting it because it's on
Loop he'll figure it out sniper one
radio
chip Bobby radio check he's going to
tell his Loop okay get your Sniper 2
radio check Sniper 2 your gun okay now
do it quick or Purge Daddy Let's Go
Leo come on now o he
knew oh there's been a breach all
right
grab all the guns oh okay they have
their silencers on someone betrayed us
what I can't trust anyone put on that
vest listen and do what purge daddy says
cuz Purge daddy knows someone's coming
to kill you you understand me
move
yes go what the hell is that nice did
she not know that that was in our own
house he must have had a built when he
did the oh I love that okay what the
hell is that that was some quick
construction is what that
was where the hell is she Jesus
Christ oh so the old man wasn't on it so
both of us were right I'm glad he's
balding yeah screw
you oh oh yeah shake him
yeah he's looking more and more familiar
there we go purge Daddy's back baby I'm
sorry Purge Daddy I didn't recognize you
with all all that
purging I don't know what the that
is okay actor get your FaceTime oh love
this guy he's a great actor um or Mark
may be outside repeat your mark may be
outside he's just such a bummer cuz he
looks like such a skin head you know I
know it's terrible like like he's got to
be villain in everything yeah I see
her
oh oh God hurry
up in the face not in the face no no no
in the chest I think oh that's better
though oh what's this what's this what's
going
on
whoa Purge Daddy had a hidden bomb that
was wild that was awesome so like what
circumstances did he foresee except for
that exact one that he would need a bomb
in that room in that room yeah well that
that computer was the old guys right was
their computer so maybe he was like I
don't know if I trust
them that some kind of H grown militia
those are skilled Merks with a lot of
money behind them enough to get to
someone on our staff I'm guessing it's
the minister the minister the NFA though
a lot of them I'm getting too
close God he had a vest on yeah but I
feel like in there anyway it's a lot of
blood Leo we should call someone dang it
that's how they get the ambulance yes
that's how the stories merge but more
importantly that's how his shirt comes
off yes get your head in the game I'm
here Roxy you brought me back you were
thinking about how the plot is going
was and not about the most important
thing we've been speaking living the
moment you
know they're tracking us I'm also not
trying to be a but they're moving
very slow yeah daddy feels a little off
his game oh God somebody shoot the Drone
yeah take take out the Drone that's a
homemade drone
purgers now what
run fast find the closest store with
wigs and be like Senator put this
on God you got to know your moments that
was a good one know your moments was
good satisfaction I
feel if I got you at home you must admit
it you cannot lie be honest it's your
best quality oh it's got a skull
attached dang cuz that drone means
business they putting a lot of work on
that drone 35 y back 15 y
up snipe
it yeah that was pretty good skills on
her part 35 yards back 15 yards up yeah
good for her what she military too
tooo that got me that got me good that
got you that got whoa he has an axe what
the I was looking at the clown oh
no no oh my godington do something
Senator she will she will yes she's not
usess she's not a dummy she's not
useless girl from the last one that we
did not enjoy ah behind you behind
you they tased them oh no this is no
bueno they're crazies and we know
they're political yep because because
they're they're dressed as a politic as
a
politic oh these are the people who are
here in this country these are the
people that we saw oh yes that came here
from the other country to kill type of
people yeah that's why they're dressed
as Americans cuz
they're did you say I brought an americ
bazooka I I think she said you're an
American like sucker Su okay this is the
American yeah whoa who no it's the guy
from above the shop owner
yes Abraham Lincoln down Senator I knew
they saw her whoa love it come with us
Goosebump City Senator come with us oh
yeah in his head he's probably like what
how the did you guys get outside like
why are you
here stay she's not
bro stay stay I got to ask you cuz I'm
just a nosy old dog how did you get
there what is in Mississippi was you
doing outside on Purge Night senator
Goodbye Blue
Cheese you're a first aid kid Leo my
security was shot I'm fine you're not
fine I'm fine you're not sit Purge mom
is going to sew you up he told her stay
she said sit that's one up hold my beer
sick you what's your name where you from
maros Mexico City but I'm been an
American citizen for 2 years you got a
record not
here what's your name pal you know what
Mr Secret Service me you should be
thanking my black ass for helping you
instead of interrogating me his name is
Joe Dixon Joe Dixon I offended you truth
to it the dumb light of the cars are
back shut up
Poli that's when the script was like
insert loud dialogue for tension yeah no
reason to actually fight make it
up that's where they were going they
they went to Go Wrap another car with
the lights get their friends they need
to call their their girl you know talk
about the medic girls they got to call
them oh yep they do you need help and
back she's really good yeah and I
brought some friends that actress's eyes
are like I feel it she gives Crazy Eyes
good here come on girl pick up I want to
purse tonight I want to purse to God
lady what lady you want a purge what
happens to these people let him come
Purge on these girls outside yes release
the beast on these outside we are
going to purge today burn this
down
I didn't like the song there was no
Melody to it not catchy at all the
lyrics weren't that creative give you a
gun but you're not on the front line
Over My Dead Body then you better drop
dead she right
Senator then you better drop dead I'm
with Leo we need as many guns as we can
get all right girl she said then you
better drop dead my mom's not going to
like this this is what the parage is all
about me getting mine you getting yours
and nobody stopping anybody bye bye
mother say good night because Here
Comes Your candy girl their extreme
close-ups are so freaky yeah just the
way that they've shot them they are
those actresses are really good and
they're doing an amazing job making them
like lowlevel menacing threats that
could really F up yeah especially
that close they lingered on that pig
mask where I was like yeah it's not like
the people we've seen in the past that
are like you know really like government
Associated could really like have high
power they're just like purging kids man
right oh here we go hit them hit them
run them over yes girl pedal to the
metal baby
yes
yes oh my God that was so exciting I
also kind of feel bad but also but also
like wait here wait so what is it do you
think that she did that gave her this
reputation oh man I don't know but
killed a lot of people oh she's not
looking around I love her yeah cuz she
got a call we need your help and she's
like yeah oh there she is get it
change my mind she's the real purge
mommy whoa shotgun to the face I got
your message
lady oh no when they open up for her oh
no I'm scared well sh please don't die
somebody else is going to where we go
the van
goh but I got a guy in there why are
they leaving now I
don't I don't know oh CU of the back
door got it go now if you stay I stay
just leave yeah take them out why can't
they all go around back yeah just kill
them maybe it's our do to help protect
her we'll rebuild the deli she'll she'll
rebuild the deli just leave it dude just
let them have all the candy hope they
are going to destroy it but she better
fix it this Senator better fix it where
are we
headed underground treeh Center service
in the Community it's completely secure
I feel so bad for him right now that's
like his life yeah why I don't get why
they couldn't have gone around the other
side they they couldn't yeah I'd be like
go run into them like
[Music]
yeah oh Jesus
Christ uh this is probably the first
time she's really seen Purge Knight up
close other than the time that her mom
had to make that choice right she un
that's also her no I think she's seeing
it who the hell is this
lady you big dope you get people from
the neighborhood a bad
name those shot sound far
oh it's Crossfire not for us but is for
someone and you are Senator yeah I hear
it dang it oh my gosh from above how are
y'all going to survive that Jesus Christ
Rondo's dead oh he was the only one we
could lose it's such a plot wise such a
shame
fight it's survival of
the like you don't think of under the
freeway as the safe place right he's the
fittest of them all stop denying him he
definitely looks like it I mean we got
one shirtless crazy person I can't
believe Rondo died I know I kind of
liked him popping in to be like who are
you guys and I kind of want him to learn
something and then maybe help Purge but
we just heard that he was a good kid did
she said Jesus Christ Rhonda's
dead can we just wait here no they'll
have units on the ground there was no
way they could have known me be in this
van doesn't matter they did I'm using
your armrest I didn't know that till now
use it up girl
thanks what is going on oh it's a
Tracker yeah that must be what it is got
it
smart oh
ask somebody else to do it also
shouldn't the EMT be like let me help
you out real quick all right help them
get it out okay Bo there's a whole bunch
of negroes coming right this way and we
sitting up here like a bucket of mother
maybe like have the senator speak right
like step out and be like I'll help each
one of you they'll start blasting if we
move they'll start blasting if we
don't leave triage alone what are you
guys thinking about what's the plan I
know what I heard I know what I heard
I told you I ain't no saint everybody's
got a past veteran was a whistle oh
whistle I said veteran thing I know
what I heard he says yeah but also he
said if this is the right set we're not
going to hurt you just help my boy he's
going to die we help you you do
something for us take this bullet yeah
but then he's going to die to the other
side of the world wow he was a holy
crap I have so many follow-up questions
then he changed his ways and opened up a
shop I said oh it must been Mill
military thing and they were like know
no she he like nope he's a
GP oh did they put it in the water smart
oh
no but why would they do that they
needed to keep it moving Earl we found
the trace bullet but no sign of the
target I'd be like once those people are
there then shoot them yeah yeah yeah
good good good go take care of them e oh
we see it says white power on your shirt
around you to come in come in I need a
sitre you know who I don't care about
getting killed white power people yeah
none of them ha Rondo I'm still upset
about yeah good kid so the bullet go
through his vest or just hit him in the
shoulder yeah good question I don't know
maybe he didn't have a vest on oh no he
didn't have a vest on cuz remember he
took off his shirt he didn't have yeah
what are we you'll
see what will we see when I find out who
she is I feel like she's
from yes that and right that shot of her
walking in there I was like was she in
The Last of Us she wasn't uh she seemed
yeah Walking Dead call this a safe Zone
oh there he is there's our guy we have
doctors and nurses EMTs
paramedics look these are the real
victims of The Purge the people that the
nffa are trying to eliminate that is sad
of tactics that you employ I am Purge
night I can't say that I agree with any
of it I'll tell you what you get elected
you stop this night and I don't have to
do what I do anymore yeah he's basically
just the resistance yeah it's one thing
in like in concept to not agree with
what he's doing but what is he actually
supposed to do it's kind of like they
have no choice they do have a choice
yeah I mean it's not a good one yeah
it's not a great one I I would do what
he's doing and be like I'm going to I
think I would too kill off these these
people like when they went to that rich
party and the last one I was like heck
yeah yeah I know I know cuz we don't
even know what his tactics fully are is
it like is it truly kill the rich or be
killed by the rich because then you have
to kill him right right or maybe he goes
after like because that rich party was
almost white power too right all
everyone was white there I think this
it's kind of the same Vibe I don't think
everybody was white there really at the
party yeah I the rich party I REM old
white lady and those old it was a lot of
white people yeah there was a lot time
to go got to get back to the de
no are you crazy we're safe here L you
know I'll walk back if I have to why
I'll drive you I mean but if we run into
any problems we're coming right back
here do why though I get you want to
protect just like Let It Go like you can
already yeah it's already like they saw
their way in I'm going to go take a look
around okay stay here yes Purge Daddy
okay boss oh see she said it she's the
vibe did I ask you did you watch l yeah
I did watch it I love lost you know her
that I just can't remember anything Roxy
apparently the only person that I really
Tru she's the doctor is the bald guy
she's the uh Island when they find her
later with Benjamin lius yeah the only
yes now I'm remembering she with Sawyer
but then with Jack with the Sawyer yes
then she with Jack and and it's Jack
Jack but then Sawyer kind of I'm not
doing a great job describing it she was
doing the fertility stuff her and Kate
had beef and then they were cool and
they had beef some of is about soer
Jack
perge maybe it's cuz you don't have the
perch pillow I don't have it
Fortress what's he doing it's almost out
of focus which is interesting why is he
like sneaky music what are you doing
here hand why are you
here maybe don't cause issues I mean he
said hand he warned y'all everybody's
okay back up we
okay all right all right what's going on
I'm just getting my weapon just doing my
job wait but you didn't do your job yet
you didn't look we didn't find out
anything yet those are The Minister's
biggest Financial supporters they have
assassination plans for them you're
going to assassinate him yeah there we
go you got there it just took one minute
you're going to assassinate the minister
tonight aren't you that's too much
Exposition for me I think she should
have only said it once yeah and quicker
yeah just like get to it I need to win
this thing fair and they are not playing
fair and square and neither should we
believe in me we that's why we're trying
to pave away from you she says there's
trucks approaching us oh this is how
they're not playing fair and square
there we go Lany I need you with third
and tox now yeah we'll meet you there oh
man there's going to be a hiccup I feel
it good thing that uh Joe was insistent
to go back to his shop so that right
this movie is
sepia I hate this night and boom they're
going to get a blow up or something oh
what they some they're going to hit a
bomb or something I feel something weird
G to happen to them they're they're
going to hit a bomb there's a bomb in
the
road Fortress for the first time
Fortress I did it Fortress you said bomb
so I thought I learned oh
no
oh that's some saw right
there kidding me well y all Can duct
yeah duck
it why didn't you guys just crawl yeah
then they said good luck out there
they're like we're not really trying to
kill you we're just making an obstacle
if you make enjoy that's a huge setup
for just a little bit of fun but hey you
guys is okay yeah thank you music's
creepy someone's up where we headed
drive out of this city get us out of
here where are we headed Drive hopeful
no she's going to make him go save him I
know it she's going to the church yeah
right like for sure she can't know about
an assassination attack and then not and
then not I have to stop them from
killing the minister if they assassinate
him he becomes a martyr and how do we do
that I don't know we have to do
something you willn't risk your life to
to save an assassin yes see I said bomb
but it was just a big truck who hit her
these just random Purge people right or
is it like the stupid white power people
in a tanker you would be so
discombobulated oh yeah oh God that was
a quick snatch and scary what happened
she said they snatched her who I don't
know oh my God you guys
what and it's in an armored okay well he
should have aimed for the tires what I
know where they're taking her I know why
she's still alive Purge Daddy's got work
to do do you know Pur mom going to help
no I know where they're taking her and I
know why she's still alive maybe to the
CH
[Music]
no these are the white power people yeah
but where are they taking her
exactly oh they're probably taking her
actually to the church cuz they're on
the bad side to the to the other guy
right maybe or other guy's going to
killer well he's playing he's playing
dirty too so maybe yeah maybe the
minister was like killer or yeah but
then why haven't they killed
her why do they have to keep her
alive yeah it's a church he's probably
going to be like step down and say it on
camera I have so many ideas resign or
die yeah there the people are going to
come save her yeah they're going to get
there to kill him but they're going to
see her La
Resistance
what is
[Applause]
this
okay are they going to are they going to
put her up on a and cross and nail her
to the Cross like a why do you think
that's what they're going to do I don't
know I don't know I just think like
what's the most up
thing wait why is she passed out why is
she why is she in a yeah let's go find a
place to wait out the rest of
this so they're just guns for hire she
was so worried he was going to be a
martyr and she keeps saying I have I'm
willing to die for it she might not make
it through this movie she might not
maybe maybe if if she does die then
everyone's like no and then that side
has to win right
like who she who's this person who is
that that looked like the guy that was
her security at her place that gave her
up but I don't think it is though well
it's been a long journey to get away
from the lies and the self deception to
this place of knowledge and awareness of
who we really are pieces of yeah
this is like you say people of Flesh we
see people of to get rid of the
fury and the hatred that poisons our
souls makes us sick makes us ugly I'm
not trying to make people hate me but
has religion ever helped
anything let's have a whole conversation
about that yeah it's so complicated
Purge and purify
say it with
me how is that practicing What You
Preach right and they're like get rid of
all the hatred and the and the pain and
I'm like but that's exactly what you you
exist for that mid need to move I need
is this I cannot wait got it got it get
it got it
good for right yeah tell them what
happened you know this lunatic
Dante yeah he's Purge daddy remember
they knew each other from last movie
from before yeah trying to get yourself
killed is that the tunnel for the
cathedral how the you know about the
tunnel speak quicker man yeah tell him
why are you ignoring him just tell him
that you tell him she's in there this is
no longer an assassination it's a rescue
it's a rescue mission and then the music
comes in and now our modern day martyr
will die for our trespasses which one is
that guy maybe it's her VP yeah like
Lawrence oh a lifelong drug addict he
wants to make amends he wants to serve
his God and His government a poor lawen
let's thank Lawrence for his
gift oh my gosh you guys are the worst
God terrible Karen Karen one Karen
two thank you Lauren Harmon will be the
first purger of the
evening oh God he looks like a pure
psychopath we're not even going to be
able to save him he's about to get
[Music]
Rondo what he going to do like carve his
heart out what your soul let the light
in you are oh my god do you think she's
feeling so bad for him right now or do
you think she's scared about herself or
bothar probably both his light entered
your heart
Haron oh God they both just come I'm so
grossed out right now he does look like
a vampire he like red around his eyes
and crackly white lips like G what is
going on you ever heard of BTS bees
buddy no matter what happens we stay
together move quicker like there's no
urgency it's like we don't really need
to stop to talk we just need to like
move and yeah I do understand it is a
movie
yeah I just wish there were more walking
talks you know this person has
threatened to dismantle everything it's
going to be such a theatrical reveal
when he pulls the cap off and yet she
tried to save his life how do you think
the audience is going to react they're
probably going to clap and get excited
cuz they're
Psychopaths yeah I know they're they're
so handshakes oh my God I hate them all
I would like all the founding fathers to
come to the altar as we eliminate evil
and Purge as one oh God the founding
fathers of of what the new country
founding fathers Association oh what
yeah nice shank all they're getting out
with the old in with the new and the new
is like white power bring it back cuz
they suck bless it be our new fing
fathers for letting us
Purge
go faster shank shank them Purge Daddy
come on shank Purge daddy in the shank
yeah oh it's going to be noise Nation
reborn all right come on snipe yeah
snipe it oh my God you've got it kid oh
oh my God bye-bye old man oh such a
sweet
shot how does she not die throughout all
this though right like and how does she
not get shot yeah
right like the vampire dude standing up
get him right like what is he what is he
doing come on y'all oh he's going to
walk away maybe he's going to find
chapstick she's
alive after all that that's surprising
but hey oh great here we
go you would think they would feel like
sacred about the
church the hell are yall doing up there
oh nice bring your ass is down
here where y'all at oh man I wanted to
see him do it but that was a cool reveal
they were so stoked like I was thank you
got got she said thank you yeah but what
about Vamp like come on she's got to
have one one or two bullets somewhere in
the arm or the leg or something that was
a full-on bullet Fest
what was that take care business Go
cover we're headed out back exit we have
her what who's him the guy that came to
kill the minister oh yeah he got it got
it got it got it yes the minister the
minister yeah I thought it was one of
the bad guys on the radio being like
this is murder if you do this you will
be no different than them out of my way
D's on a mission
man we can't be like them is that the
minister yeah yeah it looks like him
you're right as an
American oh no he's not going to kill
you yeah that when you're saying
that just shoot him in the knee and get
out of there he's going to whack him in
the head knock him out come on and what
about vampire where's the vampire yeah
where did he
go oh hello Minister did the right thing
we believed in
you
where is the vampire yeah there's
something up there is he hiding in here
I am going to beat the out of you
on Election Day Is that the name of the
movie election day right Purge election
day it's election year or election day
don't know election day good night blue
cheese good night blue cheese this isn't
election day though you mean it's not
this day is not election day right right
I feel like it was
year oh cut
oh no no no
no yeah I mean the resistance can't
can't win it the whole time did our guy
didn't die right no oh he's still it's
bad okay it was close to the but not the
he said I have one more move in me what
is
it oh he's going to just pedal the metal
the car whenever somebody in these
movies says cover me it's kind of like I
wouldn't know what that
meant like just d d du wire a
car all right yep do it let's get it
roll out of there oh he wasn't even
going to get out oh he got killed oh he
got killed sacrifice what a big
sacrifice it
was oh Purge daddy out of
ammo yeah oh what she doing
oh W
yeah
use the glass from the window and cut
him
yeah one of you is fighting for money
and the other you is fighting for the
right thing to do and the right thing to
do always wins yeah you shanked it
pretty good just then that was awesome
Terra and Roxy are watching The Purge
it's getting very bloody it's giv me the
urge to close my eyes but I won't do
that cuz she does doesn't want to purge
no I supposed to rhyme bro that was good
no you said you said urge and then I did
The Purge I started with Purge then went
to urge then I went to that and then it
was like something about a hat yeah I
brought it back in all the wrong
ways oh
okay nice come on finish him off make
sure he's dead no he's learned from the
senator that makes you know better than
them no don't do that buddy buddy
oh there he goes there is aamp there he
is oh oh no oh no not the sniper no no
I'm so sad I liked him he's out what of
ammo oh my God no he's how come on guys
good good good good good yeah come on
now oh no oh no they're going to
die no Joe I guess it doesn't matter
that your shop little sh is messed up
those dumb it's the two of them no
no she's going to take over his shop the
final scene is going to be them making
his shop into some great place for
people we got to get you somewhere okay
you going to be okay I don't think he
Isles oh good I thought he Oh I thought
he was dead oh he's going to give him
the shot yep May 26 two months later but
the purge is on the March 21st so it's
two months and a couple days yo to be
honest get it straight
election day yes cuz all of our
elections are on May 26th I am getting
word right now Florida that the senator
has also taken Florida that's what he
said she need to do yes it is now
official the next president of the
United States will be Charlie Ron that
her first order of business you're right
it's going to be them two at the shop
updates it's a landslide all right I'll
come by tomorrow we can get started on
the ceiling no I know her well from
something what is it I think by the end
of the movie I think it's Michael with
an a y or something I can't I'm just
picturing this place is really coming
along Marcos Joe would be really happy
Joe would be yeah and I now live my life
to make Joe happy nffa supporters are
reacting violently to this defeat they
are burning cars BR Windows loting
attacking police officers
oh okay setting us up for that huh James
demonico and of course it's Jason Plum
Plum House for the win and I always
forget that Michael Bay produces this
let me see these credits
baby music game strong throughout we
even had a Miley Cyrus
song okay Todd Miller
editing Whitehead that's a tough laugh
last
name Frank gillow
Frank Elizabeth Mitchell okay that's the
girl from Lost M Michael T Williams and
I said Michael Williams Oh my God I
almost got there I was like I think it's
Michael the Y and Williamson Michael T
Williamson so close yet had so far I was
I was quite far I was close and far yeah
oh but what was what was she in we'll
look it up in a little um big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a
real game changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum showing
down my internet and contacted me due to
a suspecting hacking attempt and funny
enough I realized I hadn't actually
activated my expressvpn on my new laptop
that I got a couple of months ago so I
was paying the consequences having faced
a serious hacking issue on YouTube a
couple years go that made expressvpn my
go-to for both security and freedom I
mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you
can use expressvpn to watch movies and
shows on Netflix that are not available
in your country this means accessing a
vast rate of content of over a 100
countries like a global Cinema your
fingertips it's super easy open
expressvpn switch locations refresh the
browser and there you have it whether
it's kdramas on South Korean Netflix
Hulu BBC I player YouTube or more
expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows at anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again all right so word
that'd be good that was good I was in it
uh it as in it as in one and
two no so like you were saying some of
the pacing it it did slow down a little
bit like
uh I'm
looking not not as much as one or two
there was just more I don't know maybe
it's cuz we were closer it seemed maybe
quicker maybe the state seemed higher
cuz we were in the actual environment in
two and then in one we were just in that
little house um and in this one it
seemed like the
problems were solved quickly right like
I
mean I don't know I don't know how to
explain it I still really liked this one
but I wasn't as on the edge of my seat
as I was in like one and parts of two
this one's a little difficult because it
makes you like at the end of the day I
might kill the
the homeboy what's his name the guy that
the minister Minister oh yeah yeah yeah
Minister I might because go f yourself
yeah totally and you just tried to kill
me but like you want the people in
charge to be better than you right you
don't want you to be in charge you want
the people at the top to be the example
of good yeah yeah so I like this Senator
is it realistic I mean we've never had
somebody as good run for president ever
that is that pure as she is like and
also does it really solve the problems
like we heard throughout like a a lot of
the people in this movie and rightfully
so like the main woman helping per are
the actual Purge mommy who's like yo my
people get left behind no matter what
yeah yeah I don't know it's interesting
cu the first movie like we talked about
is very isolated yeah second movie we go
out into the world third movie we break
the rules and we find out that actually
now you can go for elected officials
anybody anybody that's supposed to even
the playing field and it's almost like
by opening up those stakes and giving us
the whole world the stakes did feel a
little a little less right which is kind
of weird it was still really solid and I
don't know what I could have wanted from
a third one that they didn't deliver and
I'm glad we had Frank gillow carry
through because we needed like some yeah
some something we needed that action and
that like knowledge or like the the
maybe it's just the Nostalgia no it's
like it's like his like Purge dadness
but also his knowledge led us to
automatically associate that like he
could save the senator if they were as
long as they were together right that
like it started out really interesting
with the heist at the house right like
with them coming together her and
turning on her but I do also feel like
we didn't fully come full circle with
that like why did they turn on her the
PE her own defense you know I mean you
can assume for money because they're
working with the minister you know you
can assume but I wanted to hear was
there another side to why we didn't like
this politician you know she seems like
so good but maybe they turned on her
because maybe she screwed their families
or something you know like maybe there
was something more to the story and I
feel like that would have made it a
little more well-rounded even though it
was entertaining as hell like I kind of
am nitpicking because honestly this
whole franchise is pretty dope is great
but I agree with you because uh in I
mean they said like you're not getting
paid if she's not if she's dead or
whatever they said but I thought that
when that's why I thought when she was
in the ambulance looking out the window
and you're like no that's just her point
of view I thought it was a flashback to
her childhood with these people hanging
from the trees and I thought that maybe
that was her as a little girl dancing
and I was like are we going to go back
to that to where it's like she was bad
at one point and if any body finds out
or if they did find out that's why
they're like seller but we didn't that
wasn't that she was just I guess looking
at the Carnage we also never do come
back to her mom picking to save her life
and like what that does for a person you
know she never I kind of wanted maybe
that's why is there another one after
this yeah yeah I think so but I don't
know like do you think they're just
saving all of that it's possible but I I
wanted what I a moment that I wanted was
this is a politician I want to see her
stand up and give a big speech right
like you know I this is what happened to
me as a kid I've been personally
affected by this I have survivors
remorse everybody here does we
collectively have have experienced a
trauma like some kind of rounded out
thing you know yeah I mean that would
have been great to see also it would
have been cool if they if they had a
little more yeah backstory as to why
they would turn on her cuz she seems
like a good like a good person right um
and I'm like how much money really are
you getting but then I like ah okay fine
maybe that's the purpose of this whole
universe though that like a l is
everything yeah that's true I mean we've
learned that in both of the movies it's
not like they're going to change the
plan now that these people are out to to
make more money and kill you know the
people that they feel are lesser than
this one also felt the longest did it
feel that way to you I don't know if it
was pacing right the pacing they they
there was a lot of instead of walking
talk instead of sork and walk and talk
they did a lot of stop and talk stop and
talking stop and talk stop and talk and
lives are in danger and as I you know
it's not a real search and rescue
mission however if it was pick up the
pace baby yeah and that has to be a
direction move because if we if we just
imagine him when you know when he
reveals himself in the tunnel and
they're like who's that guy that I
imagine sure he could say it for a
second but then he's like I guess it
would be bad if he was running but I
still feel like hey it's me I need to
tell you like this isn't a blah blah
blah it's now a rescue mission where's
the tunnel we got to move like and then
they're like moving and
talking they have her they have her we
got switch yeah yeah yeah something to
really get it to where you know in
movies where they're like they're on
that mission and the the music kicks in
and now we're like really moving I
thought that was like maybe going to
happen and it still took its time yeah
it was dragging a little bit I'm super
with you on this I want to see if this
was a different director so this one was
James demonico okay and let's see no he
did he did too and two and one wow
interesting so he did he did The Purge
series he did The Purge forever he did
the What's called the F the first Purge
which I guess is The Purge after Purge
election year he did The Purge UK he did
The Purge Anarchy and he did The Purge
but he wrote The Purge did he not direct
it let's see um CU like the first one is
The Purge that we watch yeah no he
directed it he directed and directed it
okay it did feel different it really did
I'm I'm with you but it it felt slowed
down and it yeah it felt like maybe they
wanted it to breathe more but in it
breathing more I had more questions than
I had answers I got to also figure out
where that woman Betty is from okay she
was in upgrade which was a movie that I
love oh dude you know who she is the
second I opened it I realized who she
is she's the single here get out girl oh
my God that must be her right okay the
second I opened this up I was like wait
I'm looking at a picture of her yes oh
yeah she she work that's why she's so
good I mean she is so good the actors in
This franchise are so good seriously
Beyond yeah I age really really like
Beyond excellent I don't have an issue
with a single performance in this whole
franchise no not at all and I do agree
in what you said at the top this movie
and none of these movies would work this
well if the casting wasn't entirely on
point meaning with the direction and the
producing coming together going we need
that person specifically because and and
the chemistry has always been topnotch
like I've never believed if they've set
two characters up that they didn't
already have a relationship yeah but it
is wild that like we are watching an
entire Purge and my brain is thinking
make out make out make out like why does
Frank Gilla would have chemistry with a
a brick wall yeah he would he would we
got I mean they they did light up that
peack a little bit man it had like a red
light on it you guys can stop go rewind
it was good looking I think another
again this is being so nitpicky and I
don't mean to because I actually did
really like this movie while I was
watching it but because there was that
time to breathe another thing that just
bothers me about Society sometimes is
that I do think that each life is equal
every life is equal everybody's time
matters equally and we did do everything
on the planet to protect the senator and
in in protecting the senator we killed
the only guy that was in all three of
these movies like because she wanted to
stay home she was so insistent on
staying home and not being where it was
the safest place for her yeah which I
get I understand because she wants to be
a citizen and live like a citizen but at
the same time every single person died
around her including Joe including um
the like the one that I just mentioned
the kid the kid the good kid Rondo died
and and people were shot it's and
including the leader of the resistance
and so many members of the resistance
and it's just like I can I can we really
justify for saving the I get it's for
the greater good and she is about to be
the leader of the greater good and she's
going to take down the minister and she
is the best chance at the future and the
best chance at ending The Purge but at
the same time am sitting here like and
and she did fight to keep people alive
you know she did try to keep the
minister alive and she did try to um say
them we're no better than them but also
we were all protecting her even Joe at
the end jumps in front of the bullet for
her and it's like does her life matter
more than anybody else's I understand
that's what it's like to be a bodyguard
and what it is to protect the government
officials but I don't know it just kind
of irks me a little yeah I mean the one
thing that might have that might kind of
save it is that Joe at the end he's like
well the senator will take care of it
won't you senator like basically he knew
that it was for the larger picture which
does make us feel a little bit better
about it but I do agree with you that a
lot of people had to die for her um but
I guess the the the ideal is that just
the the greater picture will succeed of
like goodness over these like white
powered freaks who still want the purge
she's the only one well not the only one
but the only one that we saw that was
against The Purge in trying to like
change the world and she has all of
these people who are on her side and
then just the total opposite that's and
I'm glad that you won but I'm curious to
see the setup that they left us with
yeah me too that's that's just seems
like another Insurrection like ready and
waiting maybe it is maybe it it is
actually a good thing that it is making
me ask myself these questions you know
like what does matter most and and is
the greater good a good enough reason to
do something and you know I think that
that all these movies have made me think
genuinely and I know it's supposed to be
kind of like a silly franchise a horror
franchise but to me they gen the thought
and and even the fact that the my first
instinct when we're seeing the purge and
crime rate go down and I'm just like huh
it's an interesting concept and it's
like no dude this is a way to eat the
poor yet again like and for the
rich to keep pushing down people
that will NE you know for the 1% and
it's like every movie has really made me
deep in thought about something this
one's no different and I really I'm sure
people are like you're overthinking it
but to me they are thought-provoking
yeah they are for sure I mean I think
there were some similarities in this
like what when I was comparing the rich
white people party to like the rich
white people Minister people it seemed
like very similar like the resistance is
now going to come in and has to take
these people down because that's what
they do and and you know Senator was
saying before I don't really agree with
your methods but at the end of the day
they really are making this purge way
just way worse they really are taking
out all of the the weak people which is
why now the they have to have a safe
Zone to bring in like homeless people
and people that are like tracked after
which is so sad and now we've I guess in
this movie it's a culmination of how bad
the purge has become and how much the
people of the world have to now
sacrifice their life to save the people
in their Hood and the people that they
still want to be around so that they
don't don't just end up with like a
bunch of white power people coming into
their shop wait like coming in to buy a
Snickers and be like can't wait for the
purge next year it's going to take you
down like you know it it is like a very
no matter which way you think about it
these like you said it it is very
thought-provoking it does make you think
and there's so many ways to to like move
with these story lines but them
delivering it each and every time does
make you think like how do these people
get out of this how how do they get out
of it when we see what the president
does and we'll see what she's able to do
see what's up I mean I'd give this like
a seven seven out of 10 because of the
pacing but I think the last purchese I
was like eight out of 10 I I still I
love this I love the franchise me too
and I love frank Gill's character
because
heal
way not we got and Sh Minister but he
does do the right thing and like he's
interesting he's complex man and I I
think he's a good lead for the franchise
I hope that he's in the fourth one I
hope we get to see it which is up to you
guys like comment subscribe let us know
hopefully you are enjoying the series as
much as we are where could they go from
here yeah I mean I'm I'm gonna be
interested to see the senator and that
relationship carry out with Frank
gilla's character if we get to I mean I
would I would hope one what did I but
then I'm like what's the what's the uh I
don't know what the next one is but I'm
like what's
the what's the Resurrect The the
resistance look like because we now we
don't have our leader it's like going to
be a whole new ball game right The Purge
forever is uh written by the same person
but directed by somebody else and
completely different no knew none of the
same people oh okay so totally different
so we don't maybe we don't get a call
back to that but I don't wait no the
first Purge is next after the purge
election year comes the first Purge
which it probably throws us back to the
first Purge okay which a lot of people
I'm into that all right we got Mera to
is in this one we got I'm not gonna look
Greg I'm not looking I'm not looking I'm
not looking I won't remember said
Marissa to out loud and I'm not going to
forget that I will no mer to is not
forgettable we got to get out of here
before I blow we got to go we got to go
we love you guys thanks comment tell us
how cool we are because we love you so
much and most importantly remember to
vote later rejects
[Music]
bye